[Music]
legendary power
show me you are strong enough to carry
them
you can't outrun your destiny
i'm not afraid of you
marvel studio shanghai and the legend of
the ten
rings greeting pg13
welcome back everyone big surprise
marvel dropped a brand new shongxi
trailer video so we'll break it all down
there's a bunch of easter eggs so if
you're brand new to the channel be sure
to subscribe to get all the videos
the movie's coming out in september so
you want to wait that long for the next
really big marvel movie and everyone's
wondering when that spider-man trailer
is going to drop
don't worry i'll address that at the end
of this video too but they start this
trailer with that funny scene of the
tournament of him
actually just entering the ring for the
first time and his friend katie sitting
there wondering hey where'd your shirt
go what'd they do with it so it sounds
like they just rip it off him when he
goes into the tournament he just shrugs
like i don't i don't know i don't know
what's going on here
this might be before he winds up
fighting the abomination it might be
like the very first fight because the
way they pace things out in the last
trailer you see them standing in the
crowd
watching wong get his ass handed to him
by the abomination
who's finally back i know everybody's
wondering what he's been doing this
whole time since avengers infinity war
in the events of the incredible hulk
movie
you have to picture julia louie dreyfus
character just standing off of screen
just getting ready
to recruit him the minute the tournament
is over like hey i have a special
assignment for you
spoiler warning for the black widow
movie too if you've not seen black widow
so in the black widow movie post credit
scene we actually found out that elena
bilova has been working for her for a
while after the events of avengers end
game
so it just seems like she's going around
the mcu collecting
a group of anti-heroes in a very
thunderbolts or dark avengers type of
team
it seems like she's got the raft on
speed dial so that she can talk to baron
zemo
she also just recruited us agent at the
end of falcon and winter soldier
pretty safe bet to say abomination is
probably somewhere on her list
but he's actually going to be showing up
during the she-hulk series next so we
might not see her
actually recruit him either till the end
of shunxi in the legend of the ten rings
or to the end of the she-hulk series
kevin feige confirmed that val would
continue to show up in a bunch of
different projects
this movie is just the next big place
she could possibly show up the reason
why it seems like he might be fighting
abomination first is just because
we've only seen the footage of him
actually fighting in the ring when it's
against his
sister so i think the whole idea with
wong getting his ass handed to him and
it being kind of a funny wtf moment like
wait a minute i thought he was supposed
to be really powerful how do you get his
butt kick so easily
it just makes the abomination who looks
way more comic booky now if you're
wondering why it seems like he has the
fins on his head
that's because that's what the
abomination looks like in the comics
they just toned him way down for the
incredible hulk movie
maybe because they were afraid of him
looking too weird at the time like
marvel phase one they tended to play
things a little bit safer now that we've
gotten to marvel phase four
we've already done a talking tree and a
talking raccoon marvel probably isn't
afraid to do
really weird things with characters so
thus the more comic book accurate
looking version of abomination
and they can also play it as if he's
just evolved like his appearance has
evolved over time his gamma mutation has
evolved over time
although if you really want to reach you
could also blame it on loki and sylvia
what happened during the loki finale
speaking of incredible hulk you could
also blame the recasting the mark
ruffalo recasting of the hulk on what
loki and sylvie did like edward norton
was the hulk until loki and sylvia came
along and unleashed all the kangs from
the multiverse
there's going to be a lot of those kind
of theories flying around when things
get weird during marvel phase four
but early theory the whole abomination
versus wong fight is just to hype up
shangshi defeating abomination to make
him seem that much more powerful
than also making his sister seem that
much more powerful when she's able to
kick him around too
after he winds up kicking abomination's
ass who has just kicked wong's ass
a series of successive ass kickings the
other really big thing in this trailer
is you actually see
shengshi wielding what seems like five
of the rings of power
now there are 10 rings of power but i
think the idea here is that his father
is trying to train him to take over his
criminal empire
the ten rings organization he wants to
be good and at some point in the movie
he sort of learns to wield the same
power that his father is wielding
and learns to command the power of the
ten rings in a more complete way than
his father does
so it seems more likely that he's
actually taking the ten rings from his
father
a little bit at a time like when he's
plummeting down to earth he lands
you see the energy of these five rings
changed from blue to orange so it seems
like there's some sort of aerial fight
and the rings are actually shooting
after him
down to earth then once he takes control
of them their energy changes to orange
because in that last trailer when you
see them standing off and you see the
energy between them as if he's trying to
pull the other five rings from his
father
there's blue energy and yellow energy
like he's fighting him using his own
innate power that he's learned to
control
it seems like he's getting ready to take
the remainder of the other five rings
from his father i know there was just a
lot of confusion about what was going on
here like wait a minute did he just find
a bunch of extra rings
i don't think that's the case i think
there's still just 10 rings during the
movie
the other big thing we've learned since
the last big trailer came out is what's
going on with the great protector dragon
here that he sees
underwater and this special island with
the door that it seems like they're
trying to get into
michelle you clarified that her
character is the guardian of this secret
city so i'm assuming that she was
talking about the city that's behind
this door
on this island it has something to do
with the temple that they're fighting
over with these monks in the background
both in the flashbacks like the red
monks that he's fighting in this giant
war
and in present day when shengshi is in
his full comic book costume and he's
getting ready to fight his father
like it's the same group just during a
couple different time periods
it's still not really clear why it is
that his father wants to take control of
this place or what it is that's behind
this door that he wants so badly
but the way kevin feige explained the
mandarin character played by tony lung
who's fantastic actor he's this
amazing martial arts film so i can't
wait to see some of their fights during
this film
is they wanted to present a more complex
picture of what the mandarin was like in
the mcu like he wasn't just a typical
mustache twirling villain
so even though he's the main antagonist
of the movie he is supposed to have a
very good reason
for wanting to get into this city
wanting to control this power
it sounds like it might have something
to do with whatever happened to
shangshi's mother like you see her in
the flashbacks
training here it looks like the same
type of training that shengshi is
getting in present day from michelle
yeo's character
like she's connected to the power of the
ten rings in some way maybe she has
something to do with these people that
the monks come from
but because of all the tiny dragons
flying around during this fight scene in
what seems like present day just based
on the costumes that all the mandarins
men are wearing i'm assuming that this
is their
version of the maculans from the comics
whether or not they actually do maculans
or they explain
that this ancient culture that created
the ten rings is a little bit different
in the mcu
in the comics the people that created
the ten rings were this ancient race of
space dragons basically who came from
another planet they just got really
bored they got so advanced that they
left their planet looking for adventure
the ship wound up crashing in ancient
china and that place where it wound up
crashing became known
is the valley of the dragons and that
became the special place that they were
trying to protect this whole time
so it sounds like when they're looking
at the island here the great protector
dragon protecting this place michelle
joe's character
this is their version of that part of
the comic book story but we'll see if
they wind up changing things
and they don't wind up being space
dragons they haven't really explained
that part of the film yet
the other funny thing that you may have
noticed in this trailer it seems like it
might
just be an error based on the way they
cut the trailer and it'll be fine when
the movie gets released but during this
buzz chase scene as they're driving
through the streets of san francisco
he's got that big razor fist fight
in the other fight with his father's men
you notice the text on the bus
reads one california but it's actually
reversed
is that they filmed it completed the
special effects and then just reversed
the trailer shot like they literally
flipped this shot horizontally so the
text reads backwards
instead of the correct way i'm assuming
just whoever cut this trailer for marvel
just did it that way and when we see the
actual movie
they'll fix the text and it'll read the
correct way sometimes you'll see that
with marvel trailers like they'll change
things on purpose just to make it a
little misleading like during avengers
infinity war and avengers end game
all those trailers were just a little
bit different so you didn't know exactly
what was going on in scenes or you
didn't know how many infinity stones
thanos had at any given moment
but every once in a while just some
weird thing will just make it through
whatever their qc program is
there's a little more footage of his
father in this fight in present day in
the
white suit that you see him in earlier
in the trailer fighting this character
in green
called jiang ling it's not really clear
who she's going to wind up being or if
she's
connected to the people behind the ten
rings or if it's someone connected to
his wife but their fight seems pretty
epic so she does seem connected
to this city that they're trying to
protect here on this island
there are a lot of people that have also
asked about fing fang fume and whether
or not the great protector dragon the
giant white dragon is supposed to be the
movie's version of mcu thing fang fume
because he's a mcluhan just like the
other big space dragons that created the
10 rings but the way they've explained
it so far
is that thing fang fume isn't really a
character during the movie so they're
just
completely changing that part of the
backstory of the 10 rings
but like i explained in my last video
the interesting thing about the
mandarin's palace here is that you look
at this giant carving
all across as well as super elaborate it
basically depicts what
seems like the history of his family in
the history of the ten rings like this
giant dragon here
represents the great protector dragon
there's a door here that represents the
door on the island
when you see them wielding their power
you see it light up with the same type
of energy that shang shi is wielding
when he's wielding the tent rings later
we've already talked about how he's
basically supposed to cross over with
the avengers and avengers 5 enjoying
whatever the next roster is going to
wind up being
i don't know if they're going to wind up
doing a version of agents of atlas or if
he'll have some other team that he'll
put together
in his own franchise because obviously
there'll be sequels to this movie
but you can tell why his costume is
built the way it is so that when he's
wielding the 10 rings there's all that
dead space on his arms that they'll fill
up
even though the mcu 10 rings are like
giant bands that he wears around his
wrists
we'll see how they explain the power of
the 10 rings during the movie they're
still kind of vague about what's going
on with them
because in the comics the mcluhan 10
rings of power were actually just built
to power
their spaceship i have a feeling the mcu
explainer will be a little bit more
complex than that but if you were
wondering on a power scale they're not
really meant to be the next version of
the infinity stones they probably won't
be that powerful
just because marvel had that big joke
during loki like infinity stones oh we
use those as paperweights here in the
tva
that was basically marvel playing a joke
on the infinity saga of movies and
saying that we're kind of moving past
the infinity stones is a big plot device
even though you'll probably see them
referenced again
like we just spent 10 years using the
infinity stones as mcguffins we're not
going to go right back to that with the
next couple of movies
they'll also probably explain why just
any old character can't just pick up the
10 rings and wield their power
it seems like there's some special
innate power that shengshi has to wield
in order to be able to use the 10 rings
themselves as opposed to the infinity
stones that any person powerful enough
to pick one up could actually use if
they wanted to
so that'll explain why someone like iron
man or someone like the hulk couldn't
just pick up one of the 10 rings and use
their power
but if you spotted any brand new easter
eggs in this new footage that i didn't
talk about during this video just write
it below in the comments i know people
still wondering about what's going on
with wong why is he fighting in this
tournament does he need sandwich money
what's going on
the actor who plays wong benedict wong
actually said that he made a big deal
about wanting to be in the shengshin
movie when he found out that they were
making one so it sounds like he lobbied
behind the scenes to get himself in the
movie
and they just found a really clever way
to include him and as for the spider-man
no way home trailer it does sound like
marvel is still planning on releasing
the movie at the end of the year i don't
think that that's changed or anything
like that
but kevin feige said that their
marketing departments at marvel and sony
both coordinate so
they don't overlap their trailers too
much worst case scenario i think is that
the way to the shangshi movie hits
theaters and they'll just attach
the spiderman no way home trailer to
that but there'll be a whole bunch of
videos coming up marvel's what if series
is going to be the next big thing i'll
be doing videos for that'll start really
soon in the next couple of weeks
make sure you have alerts enabled for my
channel so you don't miss any of those
everyone click here for my brand new
loki video about how iron man
knew about kang in the mcu and click
here for that brand new first look at
ben affleck's batman in the flash movie
thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you guys tonight
you